Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome to "I Don't Even Know." Now that's the name of the game.
I found this after I played the "World's Easy-est Game" in the quiz category and so...
I don't know what it's about, but I'm gonna play it! Ploy?
PLoY?
Ploy... Okay fine. Free too won GOGH. Which men stole teh cookie? *laughs* I- *laughs again*
Not I, I am a cookie! No is me, I ain't hayv arms!
Myself is not man!
You? No. You? No. You? No. Oh-
Hi
Oh Shit...
Hi, Welcome to the party Little guy. How you doing? Next mission...
"Click in Steve"...is that Steve?? oh hi. Oh excuse me... sorry I'm sorry OH NO
Oh okay, I thought that was gonna kill him.
"Have him get eat"??
*grunts*
*mark struggling*
Okay, I don't know what-huh? What is he eating?
What is he eating?! I don't know what he's eating. uh oh- uh oh... this seems bad. No Steve don't do it D:
Oh my pet.. Next mission, weh. "how joo make a'splode"?!
I don't know!
Key? No. This blonk? Shwampo?
Key? Ok, key's in..ooohh alright ahhhh... oh well ur not allowed
Okay, next mission *giggles* Cover his NUDE
ohh.. his tasteful nudes need to be covered up EEEHHH
Boss defeat.. defeat Mr Clown...... how?
How do I do that.... Honka? Honka? Do I BLOW HIM UP? Do I B to blow him? How do I do that??
Wait... Hello! Oh! D:
OH NO!!  Awwww...
He's sad now.. oh draw? What am I drawing?!
Oh... hi. That's not- that's not a drawing... it's very abstract art awwwww shit next mission... What light are hawter?
*stumbles upon words* OH MY GOD
Ow Ow! Ow!
This one? Oh shiitt
okay... Fix rocket plz
Pizza... obviously needs to go in the fin there.
This 2x booster, I guess, gives points to dexterity... just shove that behind there... I guess...
Put pizza in? Ok..put plant in. Uhhh put gear. Ok! Did I do it? Find mehh
Who is you??
Who is you? oh! Hiii *giggles*
Airport security *makes noises*
*more noises*
Your nipples are dangerous today sir... *MORE noises*
*noises* oh! HEY!!
What did he- What did he have in his head... Paper or plastic ma'am *noises* I'M NOT A MA'AM
Oh...hi
Not... both... *giggles*
Next mission... Anybody home? Ding dong.. bing bong. Break in through the window dong... party in your house all night long
Anybody? bing bing bing bing bing bing bing... oh hi yes HELLO!
Have you heard the good word?
"You is teh life of teh party"... I'm also flying above it
I think I'm gonna die.. oh YEEH OH YEAH HELL YEAH oh good.. oh look at meh
Oh fuck yeah!
Next mission. Dance show get! Oh shit! Hell yeah! :D
This game's so charming... Next mission. Enjoy my surround sounds!
Yes..yes! Ok.. next mission. Make an wish...
I gotta make an wish *noises as he blows out candles*
*more noises*
Wish came true!
That makes it hard to masturbate if I have a claw hand.. Deal or not deal?
Stop! Are joo sure.. I don't know
Hello! OH NO! My earring! I guess that's the end of that one...
Joo is so stealthy!
I'm a whale. That seems pretty stealthy to me!
No, oh, baby pretty stealthy, baby
Oh! A turtle. The stealthiest of the mammals. Robo! Not very stealthy- ninja *gasps* bye... Next mission
Deny agreement.. official contract "I agree to eat nasty foods, signed" I agree to-
Oh noo!
I didn't want that Mr.. Funky. Hey! OH! Uh oh!!
Where are Harry Potter?
And they're in moaning Myrtles bathroom. Where are-
Magic Boy
Hi! um. I is lost
Chamber of Secrets very dangerous... Hide evidence. Oh is this all my porn? ohh I don't need these anymore! Oh
Put the internet in the recycling bin. Ok. Where is my fireworks? I don't know why they'd be in the grill but ok...
It's locked. Why is the grill locked?
*Noises*  Ohhhh *Giggle* Shiiit
Boss defeat. Joor licence mister! How bout a Best Buy gift card? You like that? *giggles* I love Best Buy.
Next mission. I don't even know! *noises* I don't know. Right click?
Click here to end teh game!
Choose not to win cuz if you mention the game you just lost the game no. Oh, okay *grunt*
YAAYY!
I did it! I think.. I don't know... nice nips! ohh those dangerous nips. I knew the police would come after my nips someday
Well I guess that's it then...
Aww that was adorable! ohh that was so charming!! Aw I love that.
I mean, it was totally ridiculous n' bullshit but it was so fast-paced
I didn't even know the difference. HOORAY
It appeals to my ADD!
So anyway that is I-I don't even know. So thank you everybody for watching.
So thank you everybody so much for watching and as always, I will see YOU in the next video. BUH-BYE!
Lemme know what you thought of this down in the comments below, I have no idea who even made this but if you did, congratulations, this was kind of fun!